this year we have taken the most time
out of anyone but it is the best season
yet The Stranger Things cast and crew
have had to deal with their fair share
of incredibly painful Prosthetics and
costumes over the years and season 4 is
no stranger to that it's one of the most
painful Seasons yet ready to find out
why it's a dark dark season for me
number one nine hours in the makeup
chair plus 12 hours of acting plus an
hour and a half back out of makeup you
don't have to be good at math to know
Jamie wasn't sleeping okay nine hours is
exaggerating while it initially took
that long they managed to get it down to
six hours and 20 minutes with a team of
four working on Jamie Campbell Bower
non-stop Jamie donned roughly 25
Prosthetics that were glued to his skin
every day and the thing is they weren't
reusable so they ended up having roughly
25 copies of 25 Prosthetics that's over
600 prosthetic pieces it's me underneath
the Prosthetics it's my voice it's me
moving Barry Gower said we would spend
the best part of five hours just purely
gluing the appliances onto his skin then
we'd have an hour and a half of
airbrushing and joining all the dots
together with the paintwork and
airbrushing veins and blending
everything when Sadie sink first saw him
she couldn't stop laughing because she
was so creeped out and unsettled the
prosthetic was roughly 90 percent
practical the only thing added in post
was those pulsing veins so it makes
sense why it freaked her out number two
teeny tiny ear holes make for difficult
creature acting trying to get the voice
for vecna was problematic thanks to the
prosthetics
Jamie Campbell Bower said I was in ADR
for the show a couple of weeks ago and
the engineer was like I've got this
octave for you by that the engineer
meant a voice disorder Bauer's response
was oh no we don't use that the engineer
didn't believe him and so he did the
voice and so says Bauer the engineer
said right yep I've canceled the Octave
of that it's off now but it was much
harder when they were filming versus
being in the booth because the suit goes
over the ears and the ear holes are
incredibly tiny it was quite difficult
and distorted trying to hear himself
speak number three when will they leave
daycare alone core daker Montgomery has
been through some of the most horrific
Prosthetics experiences he's basically
fine but he has spent his fair share of
time in the makeup chair and season 4 is
no different and we're not gonna lie
having your stomach completely wrapped
in Prosthetics with red goo dripping
down you just does not sound like a fun
time number four that feel when you
quite literally work your butt off and
they demand you put it back on David
Harbor is no stranger to extreme
fluctuations in weight for roles and
stranger things brought in the starving
prisoner Hopper so when it came to
flashback scenes Harbor could not escape
the weight he burned off and had to
carry it around in the form of
Prosthetics but you know what he's proud
of his dad bod number five it has to be
seen to be believed in order to save
himself from being murdered by vagna
Victor kriel gouged out his own eyes the
gower's team designed the scarred eyelid
prosthetics for the character played by
Robert Englund having limited access to
your vision is enough to drive anybody
insane number six what do you do when
you can't use a safe word Christopher
strand's mouth and eyes were sealed with
prosthetics the crew then drove him to
the set and fastened him to the chair
head of the makeup Department Amy L
Forsyth said he couldn't see he couldn't
speak all he could do was hear when we
were breaking for lunch I was like you
better let him know he's done for the
day before you call lunch because he
might just be sitting there thinking
you're abandoning him not having access
to all of your senses can cause unwell
welcomed reactions from actors
discomfort being the least of your
concerns and things like claustrophobia
being high up on the list so the makeup
crew did their best to cater to his
situation Forsyth continued you ask them
to be very communicative with you on
their experience so that you can help
make adjustments if need be no one knows
their comfort level like they do since
strand had both his eyes and mouth
covered the makeup team only asked yes
or no questions to Gage if he was
feeling okay number seven is this what
heaven looks like because it sure feels
a lot like the upside down wearing white
contacts really limits your vision and
so anybody who entered that trance-like
state could hardly see a thing the whole
room became a milky white color and the
costume Department did their best to
prepare the actors for their experience
Forsyth said I took a lot of videos of
people putting their contacts in for the
first time to get the reactions and try
to make it a little fun experience for
them number eight did nobody tell Gayton
that he should bring sensible clothes
camping while geyton Matarazzo is a huge
fan of his costumes from the series
season 4 4 being his favorite so far he
can't help but despise just one outfit
he's worn over the years saying I have
to say my least favorite look had
nothing to do with the design in fact
it's one of my favorites but the camp
outfit always felt really tight and Tiny
he's referencing the Camp Nowhere
episode from season three number nine
would you prefer to be wet or sticky all
day stakers dealing with sunburns when
he's meant to be pale and is pale when
he's meant to have color Amy from that
hit apartment had all that fake tan this
one was a pain for the makeup Department
because after he'd burned himself
filming a pool scene he had to film the
shower scenes as the Mind flare and kept
slamming his back against the wall which
would take off all the cover-up and that
isn't all he was completely coated in a
layer of sticky lip gloss in order to
main that wet Sheen which he thinks is
better than being wet all day number 10.
that feel when you have no idea what
you're doing but you have to do it
anyways it reminds us of math class
daycare wore 30 three prosthetic wounds
for the Post sauna scene and
problematically when Millie Bobby Brown
broke her knee right as the shutdown was
lifting all of his scenes were moved up
meaning there was a rush order on all
those Prosthetics the designer had no
idea what she was even working with yet
and just created 50 different random
wounds hoping it would work out they
also asked if they wanted Billy to bleed
red yes said the director who changed
his mind in a few shots which ended up
being left to the VFX crew to fix in
post number 11. masking real wounds with
fake ones daker had only so many
Prosthetics that he didn't even realize
he bruised and cut himself all over the
place he only noticed after he removed
them at the end of the day I was covered
head to toe in cuts and bruises and I
took all the skin off the top of my toes
number 12. sure playing a creepy alien
zombie monster is cool in theory the
demogorgon was played by actor Mark
Steger in the first season of stranger
things however it was so uncomfortable
to try and maneuver around in they
replaced the real actor with CGI The
Following season number 13. Prosthetics
are uncomfortable under the usual
circumstances in season 2 when Billy
beats the snot out of Steve Steve was
already feeling a little gooey the guy
was pretty sick and to make matters
worse he had to have Menthol blown into
his eyes in order to get the desired
look
his Prosthetics included a swollen jaw
lump a cut split lip and a mixture of
cotton and dried blood oh and real snot
apparently number 14. white contacts
black contacts what's next Will's black
contacts made his eyes burn and despite
how warm everything looks on screen it
was actually very cold on set and Will
was not dressed for the weather number
15. this is a friendly reminder to wash
your face Nancy Dyer put makeup on to
cover up her acne and that caused more
acne isn't it ironic while not
necessarily painful it would play on her
self-esteem ugh we feel you Nancy all
too well
from uncomfortable to irritating to
painful to downright unbearable The
Stranger Things Gang has experienced it
all huh would you rather deal with every
single painful thing we mentioned in
this list or would you rather fight
vechna let us know your thoughts in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things